eh what is up guys of kbfd here and
today we're gonna be talking Samsung
Galaxy s5 the inevitable successor to
the oh so popular Samsung Galaxy s4 so
whenever we see a new phone in Samsung's
Galaxy S line up or Galaxy Note lineup
they tend to bounce off each other in
terms of where they get their design
cues from so the galaxy s5 I'm expecting
a phone very similar to the Galaxy Note
3 that we have now so let's go and check
out these specs first of all the backing
material that we see on the Galaxy Note
3 this leatherette sort of soft touch
back that's made its way through the
entire samsung phone and tablet lineup
and I don't think there will be any
exception with the galaxy s5 I'm
expecting to also see that here to
complete the entire look also the size
of the galaxy note 3 also if you've seen
the review have this sort of metal sort
of band around it that I guess make it
feel more premium or at least Samsung
wants you to feel that it feels more
premium so I'm expecting also to see
that on the galaxy s5 so it'll it'll
feel kind of like a shrunken down galaxy
s5 into a slightly smaller body but
again with the premium specs that we
expect out of a flagship and with those
premium specs the number one thing that
is probably most locked in is the new
camera on the galaxy s5 and that's
expected to be a 16 megapixel camera and
along with that new resolution I would
also expect it to be able to shoot 4k
video just like the Galaxy Note 3 can
around the front there is a 50/50 shot a
pair of rumors of scenario 1 and a
scenario 2 that we could see with the
way the front of this phone looks so the
galaxy s5 could either rock case number
one a 5-inch 1080p display again maybe
5.2 inch but again not upping the
resolution or particularly anything
crazy going fairly conservative with the
upgrade case number two would be a
slightly larger maybe five point two to
five point four inch 2560 by 1440
display so going with qHD 2k display and
particularly upping the ante in terms of
resolution and dpi now a lot of the
benchmarks that we've actually seen that
we have leaked apparently from the
galaxy s5 seem to indicate that case
number one is much more likely I'd give
it sixty five seventy five percent
chance of seeing another 1080p display
in the
Galaxy s5 it's not set in stone it's not
a hundred percent but we're seeing 480
PPI we're seeing 5.0 inch display and
we're seeing 1920 by 1080 these
benchmarks are also indicating that
we're gonna see another Snapdragon 800
chip not the 805 but a slightly upgraded
more powerful version of the Snapdragon
800 chip which is still a great chip
obviously this was the antutu benchmark
that we saw leaked and it was still
scoring above the galaxy note 3 and
above the sony xperia z ultra so if it's
benchmarking above these high-end phones
I don't think it'll have any problems
with performance we're also seeing 2
gigabytes of RAM and that should be more
than enough to push those 1920 by 1080
pixels it'll also be running Android
4.4.2 KitKat out the box right now that
is the most current version of Android
and you know maybe when it launches 2
weeks later there will be a newer
version of Android and we'll have to
wait for those features but at launch it
will have the newest version of TouchWiz
on top of Android 4.4.2 KitKat so
overall it seemed like a relatively
incremental or it's not a revolutionary
phone but it's it's an incremental
upgrade from the Galaxy s4 a pretty safe
bet for Samsung to sell a lot of them
again but there are some other slightly
less likely slightly more far-fetched
rumors I might as well address them
because they're out there and people are
talking about them but I don't
necessarily believe any of these are
particularly likely number one being
ditching the physical button Samsung is
pretty much locked in to their physical
home button and capacitive back and menu
buttons on their phones and tablets and
I don't expect this to go anywhere
anytime soon unlike another phone that
I'm going to talk about and also we're
hearing rumors of a possible 128
gigabyte version of the galaxy s5 that
would actually be awesome I would love
to see 128 gig version of any phone the
iPhone hasn't had one no Android phone
has had one no Windows Phone has had 128
gig version so I'd love to see that
you've also heard rumors of a retina
scanner or a fingerprint scanner
fingerprint scanner being the obvious
copy of the iPhone 5s and its touch ID
system I don't really expect to see that
that's just not something that Android
phones have gotten down pact and Samsung
doesn't take quite that extreme risks
with their phones and also a retina
scanner being something that scans your
iris or your eye or retina and looks at
your eye to lock you
or log you into your phone I don't think
that's gonna happen
Samsung has enough problems already with
their current eye tracking system just
to tell if you're looking at the phone
or not so I can't imagine it having that
much more advancements in order to be
able to tell whose eye is looking at the
phone so I would put these rumors that
like the five percent probably not going
to happen categories overall there's
really nothing particularly stunning
here with these new rumors but it's
still gonna be interesting to see a new
phone with the new design again I like
the Galaxy Note 3 so I'd like to see a
shrunken down version of it also we have
to remember that even though the specs
seem like a small incremental upgrade
Android 4.4 KitKat has way lower system
requirements and is better optimized to
take advantage of lesser specs so even
though it has a similar CPU on the
Adreno 330 GPU it still should be able
to perform better than it does now on
Android 4.3 because of the improvements
to KitKat either way I'm sure pretty
much all the rest of the details of this
phone are going to be leaked sooner or
later before the phone is actually
announced because it's 2014 and
everything leaks at this point but there
is a Samsung unpacked event on February
24th and all the systems seem to point
toward that being the place where we
first see the new Samsung Galaxy s5 so
I'll be there and I hope maybe we'll see
an updated wearable companion perhaps a
new Galaxy gear at that event as well a
little bit less likely but I'm really
focused on the phone here so either way
that's been it if you're if you're not
really into the Samsung Galaxy lineup if
you're more into the HTC One perhaps I
have also uploaded a video today it's
linked below that like button going over
the potential successor to the HTC One
so if you want to check that out that
was also uploaded today definitely don't
miss that and other than that I'll talk
to you guys in the next video thanks for
watching guys peace